[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started let's just pay the
bills right now
[Music]
Main Street boxing James this is all the
main street fighters come from 100% as
you can see there's a lot of bags full
size ring for your Olympic training a
lot of Champions came in and out of this
place come in and train young and old
every bag imaginable speed bag heavy bag
full body bag full size ring combat talk
with the King now as long we got Jose
Benavidez versus Bud Crawford alright
Terence Crawford now what you got to
understand is um in this fight these two
fighters have been circling each other
um when bud was Ginny Walter Wade
kingpin he down they cleaned it up was
undisputed undisputed means when you
hold all the belts in that division all
right so you are the universally
recognized champion by everyone so you
know bud cleared that up and he moved up
when he moved up before Jeff horn and
said Jeff owns belt the belt that Jeff
only took from Pacquiao and that
controversial fight in Australia they
stacked the deck against Crawford going
into that fight tried to make it 100%
for Horne in every fashionable way I
thought actually Horne will give him a
rough a fight then what happened because
he was coming up in wait to fight horn
and what Terence did was go out and
clinically beat the brakes off this dude
Taryn
Crawford is quintessentially one of the
most well rounded fighters that you will
see in this era he's a throwback fighter
he is a fighter of unparalleled skill
all right he can about South South Pole
and Orthodox South boys when you leave
which right hand jab Orthodox is a new
lead with your left hand job all right
he can move seamlessly he has done so
has dismantled champions former
champions and become an undisputed
junior welterweight champion he has
terrorized the junior welterweight
division fighters left the division to
get away from bud Crawford bud Crawford
to me is Bob Aram's that's his promoter
his manager his single most commodity
alright he has no much ankle but no
match angle has a loss but doesn't have
a loss but is universally known as one
of the baddest men on this planet but
it's probably the only person that calls
out
Errol Spitz we all know arrow Spence is
that dude all right
now we going to Jose Benavides Jose
Benavidez jr. is Walter wait he was
Walter wait champion he no longer has
that belt to fight but you know for
Bud's belt
I had to relinquish his belt going to do
so oh he's undefeated
like I said he turned pro at the age of
17
what promoters do what Bob Arum did was
he went out and got groups of Fighters
right he gets groups of fighters at cuts
rates and then he also buy premium
fighters now when you take these
cut-rate fighters and not to diminish
any accomplishments that these fighters
may have or these fighters may actually
achieve inside the ring not to diminish
this at all but there's a tear to this
right so what you have to do is if you
learn how stable you have to feed your
steady premier crop of fighters steady
stream of fighters all right so you try
to keep the money in house
in doing so sometimes you get gems Jose
Benavidez jr. is a gym
all right there's a lot of times by
brown will probably put him in vitamin
maybe Jose twas 50/50 cause they pulled
it out Jose is I believe 24 and Oh with
18 knockouts but Crawford is I think 33
and 133 you know with 27 knockouts he's
at 70% um Jose Benavidez is at 60%
Jose Benavides is an unknown quantity
because he has not been able to fight
the elite talent as but but what he has
been doing he has been calling but out
he told bud that he's been ducking him
he told bud that you know all types of
derogatory things all right that
actually spilled over into the weigh-in
they had the weigh-in folks the weigh-in
they came in perfectly
147 they was definitely ready to get it
on get it mixing but at the weighing
Jose Benavidez when he went to face off
he push but but instinctively throws a
right cross well a right hook in his
case because he is in southpaw and Jose
being a me this week did effortlessly
like inches off his face
so that that means that he would been
able to counter punch at that point time
alright so I don't ever call for
anything of that nature that's
unsportsmanlike I mean come on guys you
got to keep it between the lines you
know when the fight starts then that's
the when the fight happens when people
do things of this nature it shows me
that there was some past the graveyard
they may have some butterflies they may
have you know cuz you want to get it all
and you need you know once you're
already in a fight then it's a fight so
these two individuals are almost risk
losing the purse or most risk losing the
fight a whole bunch of things that was
idiotic on Wolfman part but hopefully
they can rectify this in the ring I
believe that this fight will be insane
from round one
because you have two guys who have
definitely got dog and I'm they
definitely got that pit bull and I'm
they definitely got that fight
they definitely gonna perform like
fighters you understand what I'm saying
um we got Jose Benavidez who wants to
back up his claims that but isn't the
guy that you think he is and he's the
guy that he is and he wants to show but
that I'm going to take those belts off
for you he did all types of things he
talked about bob mama you talk about
blood training talk about blood himself
so let me tell you something going into
this fight there is a lot of bad blood
and that black bad blood will be spilt
in the ring you will have a hell of a
barnburner now if you do not have ESPN
Plus you are not seeing the fight Bob
Arum side to deal with ESPN Plus that's
to keep him afloat keep him away from
our hate me who has snatched up Showtime
CBS and some things on Fox because
that's on Fox fs1 you understand yeah al
Heyman is crazy out in these streets you
have also Eddie her
he has Daz and network and with the sky
network that's out there and overseas so
his fight is fight the his stable fights
there he's following the traditional
promoter mode where you Bob Arum the
situation you Don King the situation and
you try to just keep your fighters
fighting their fighters now Haven does
that to a degree but our Heyman is not
above making matches that makes sense
alright so you got to understand it has
to make sense for Al Haman to make these
fights Oh
my prediction going into this fight barn
burner you might get a draw like draw 9s
fight does I don't ever want this to
come off wrong to Jose Benavides all
right I believe that you're one hell of
a fighter I actually believe that one
day you will probably take over the
division I actually believe that you
will probably be that dude today is not
that day
I think but once blood I think bud is
not going
think butters gonna probably knock you
out between the ninth and the tenth
round but we can a body even though
you're the taller fighter you have 510
with 73h reach but is 5/8 where the
70-inch reach he's gonna get inside that
jab he's gonna probably I'll jab you but
it's faster but I will believe is
stronger to the body but it's just a
more confident fighter he behaves as a
fighter he moves as a fighter he doesn't
take a back step as a fighter I seen but
hurt and I seen bug come back alright so
you understand I believe that bud will
be victorious in this fight with the 9th
or 10th round KO this is combat talk
with the king
and this has surprised me that everybody
wanted me to do this fight everybody
wanted me to talk about this fight this
has surprised me that lets me know that
boxing is alive and strong tonight
somebody o has got to go
[Applause]
[Music]